always been a little weird i would hang
out in book shops but never read the
books
you know i mean like i remember one time
i was um
ellen ginsberg was at a book shop who's
ellen ginsberg he's a poet
oh alan ginsberg yeah oop boy that made
you look stupid huh
i'm sorry that made me laugh
cause you you delivered it in such a way
like
like oh he's a poet you guys obviously
don't read
and then she was like you mean and then
you looked
dumb
[Music]
am i right he delivered it like
i'm sorry dum-dums i didn't know i was
talking to people that don't
read yeah he is a poet and then she's
like
oh you mean yeah and you were like
i don't you're laughing let me know hey
you're laughing way too hard friend
you're laughing way too hard with me
right it hurts me
okay why do you do that so anyway why do
you always treat him the worst
like always every time i'm on this show
hey
the worst he's such a nice guy yeah he
is very nice
so anyway i used to hang on a bookstore
sorry about the allen yeah yeah and mr
mr ginsberg
[Music]
this guy dennis owned a book book store
and um he goes
ginsburg is here come hang out and i and
i used to hang out and we wish to talk
and stuff and drink coffee
you talked to him oh yeah he wrote me a
letter wow
why isn't that hanging in here i lost it
oh my god that's alan ginsberg
and one of my yeah i might be able to
find it though but yeah he wrote
he should find that he wrote me a little
letter you know that's cool because he
thought he found me to be um
weird bro i was just about to say it and
in my head i go don't walk on him
yeah let him let him deliver this
because i because i
you know at the time obviously couldn't
get girls
had no money but i also would like i
liked the local music and i would go to
art shows and you know i was like kind
of like
floofy in that way yeah and then i would
just hang out at bookstores and play
chess
with people were you funny though like
yeah i was a funny guy right yeah i was
funny but it's like
it was emo i was kind of emailing yeah
yeah i could see that yeah
i would there was a point where i grew
my hair down to my ass wow i mean i
gained weight and i was kind of that guy
for a while and uh
i was just trying to find my way and
then um when
the band kicked me out of the band lacks
in superb
i you're really in a band oh it's online
you can see it
i gotta watch this yeah actually i'm
gonna post this yeah
if you put on laxton's superb i love it
you can see me play keyboards in a band
wow that's right you do
play the piano yeah yeah so i played
keyboards and then they kicked me out of
the band and then
i was walking down the street on um
gerard
right by the comedy store and i got a
job there
really yeah but were were you a fan of
stand-up
before that yeah because i used to work
with this girl named rebecca druskin
at a coffee shop